even by his own enigmatic standards it's
been difficult to keep up with but Elon
Musk has now agreed to buy Twitter
possibly bringing to an end one of the
most high-profile corporate battles of
recent times
in a letter via his lawyers musk made an
offer for the previously agreed price of
44 billion dollars and experts say the
deal is almost done
I don't know how quickly they can get
their hands on on like literally the
cash to pay uh people but presumably
relatively quickly procedurally they've
had the shareholder vote they've gotten
a regulatory approvals so in terms of
actually making it happen from that
perspective it's literally at this point
just filing a piece of paper in Delaware
shares in Twitter Rose about 13 before
being haltered as news filtered through
that musk had agreed to purchase at that
price the world's richest person first
reached a deal to buy Twitter in April
before beginning a legal battle to
extricate himself he said Twitter had
misled him about the number of fake or
spam accounts on the platform
if the deal does now go through musk
will avoid a showdown against Twitter in
a U.S courtroom scheduled for just two
weeks from now
it will also reignite questions about
the future of Twitter musk has pledged
to make the platform more free speech
oriented including reinstating the
account of former president Donald Trump
it was not correct to ban Donald Trump I
think that was that was a mistake
um because it uh it alienated a large
part of the country
and from musk yesterday this tweet
saying the purchase of Twitter will
accelerate the launch of his everything
app
but that is exactly isn't yet clear
Martha Kellner Sky News Los Angeles